alright let's do it alright folks it is
finally here the premiere of series 11
of Doctor Who Jodie whiticus first
adventure the woman who fell to earth
now before I get too much into the
specifics of it I want to start by
acknowledging the fact that first
adventures for doctors usually are ok I
mean let's be honest because a lot of
people for good or for ill are gonna put
a lot of pressure on this specific
episode and put a lot of weight on it
but look let's be honest especially if
we restricted to the modern era I would
argue that only Matt Smith how to really
knock it out of the park first adventure
Rose which was the first time we saw
Eccleston doctor was good enough but it
wasn't phenomenal there's a lot that was
very off about it
tenens first venture the Christmas
invasion it's ok when he's in it it's
pretty good 11th hour is great and then
deep breath is decent but again not even
close to being the best work that we
would get from the character or from the
writers for that matter so I think there
is going to be an undue amount of
pressure being put on to this episode
which it just doesn't deserve shouldn't
get but is gonna be what happens
regardless because that's the culture at
this point so having said that how is it
it's pretty good I think I'm gonna be
upfront about this I'm not 100% on with
Jodie Whittaker yet that said like I'm
not always immediately in tune with the
doctors some of them get me
right off Eccleston got me right off
Smith got me right off Tennant mostly
had me and then he picked up after that
Capaldi honestly I didn't start loving
him till his second season his second
series on the show so you know it can
take it can take more than one go so
with with this with Whitaker I think the
first thing to me is I'm already feeling
what I had been afraid of before which
is that this is too many characters and
I because I think back to the the first
adventure for a doctor that I love which
is 11th hour and a big part of I think
why that one is better honestly than all
the rest of the others is that it does a
full and proper focus on the doctor
honestly he is in I think almost every
scene in that episode the focus is on
him even as it's introducing you know
new companions and a new setting and all
this stuff it's still filtering it
through him we are focused on him it's
all about him whereas here they do the
more typical thing which is that okay
well here's a bit of these companions
here some setting here some of this oh
look there's the doctor she turned up
and now here's a bit more of the edits
it's spreading it out across the whole
cast which it's not an invalid way to do
it especially if you want to sort of
endear the companions to us but for me I
want to know this doctor I wanted a much
bigger emphasis I wanted a much bigger
laser focus I wanted a much bigger
showcase for the doctor then I feel like
I got out of this episode as far as you
know when she was the focus and she had
her moments it's good so far I've got no
complaints about it there was an
interesting thing though I am finally I
am having to adjust my brain a little
bit and I don't know well I'll first
I'll admit I don't know if this happened
for anyone else but I suspect even if it
did a lot of people aren't going to
admit
this but to be blunt about it there's a
number of things that are standard for
Doctor Who that felt a little off now
that it was a woman and I'm gonna cite a
specific example so people can try and
get one I'm sorry mark cuz I'm not
talking about she comes in and saves the
day and she's technically proficient
like no that's fine
what I mean is something like her
getting her new outfit so when it was
pointed out by I think it was yaz you
know you've got to get out of those
clothes and yeah it then cuts to you
know outside of a changing room in a
store the like my gut instinct was like
oh for god sakes this is a dressing
montage like how those things annoy me
and there are cliche in female centric
entertainment but I had to step back you
go with the doctor always has a very
tacked on way of getting their new
outfits you know it just kind of gets
inserted somewhere usually somewhat
awkwardly and this is not really any
different than that but it felt
different and it felt more derivative
somehow because women having clothing
you know you know a new set of clothing
being a big deal is something that
carries in a weird way a different kind
of baggage so but again and I've said
this before about the baggage involved
with the doctor becoming a woman that's
not a fault of the show it's baggage
that I have that I need to um I need to
decouple this crap because as soon as I
realize because I had that initial
thought that was a gut reaction and then
I thought well no cuz the doctor always
has these these sorts of moments you
know with getting a new outfit and
whatnot and then sort of honestly being
a little bit embarrassed be a little bit
of shame that like why why why is that
going on but I so like but I still want
to own up to it I did like it's it's
it's still strange for me I am happy
that Jodie Whittaker is the doctor I'm
excited for what happens but look it's
still it's it's weird it take it's gonna
take some getting used to I suspect in a
way that for many fans who got in on new
who and like had never done classic
probably having the doctor be as old as
Capaldi was was probably something that
was weird
to them seemed weird and seemed wrong so
you know III think there is those kinds
of adjustments to be made and at and I
expect that I'll make them as far as
plot goes for this one it's made its
solid you generally don't get your
amazing plots in your opening episodes
because you've got so much crap to
establish you know because you've got to
establish the doctor in the cranes and
all that coming back to the Companions I
like I I don't just like any of them but
I am left thinking do we need all three
and I'm already annoyed at seeing the
doc or at least feeling like I'm seeing
the doctors time cut down because we
have to make time for three other people
well actually previously was for other
people but they you know they they got
rid of someone who was kind of part of
the group and then not like that's a
spoiler anything because it's not like
someone who was marketed as be your
companion is like wait they didn't make
it like no it was a superfluous
character but sort of look I'm gonna
start getting into specifics and
spoilers a little bit so if you haven't
seen the episode yet which at this point
you shut up I don't even have a watch on
and know why I did that
at this point you should him by the time
this video goes up so you know whatever
so like grace Grahams wife and Ryan's
you know grandmother dying it kind of
bugged me it kind of like I had hoped
for a more like kind of a dynamic
relationship where you know maybe she
decides to hold down the fort but she
encourages him to go out on an adventure
which I you know I had that fun I
thought maybe Biggs like that could be a
real interesting dynamic and
not gonna happen said she's just dead so
instead they just removed the reason
that two out of three of those
characters would have to ever want to
come back which I mean it'd serve as a
practical function sure like it did it
it will help avoid the domestic we got
to keep going back to earth to check in
with love will do one's thing which
tends to annoy me so like that's not
again that's not necessarily a bad thing
but it's still it struck me as the
really cheap solution that said I do
kind of like the dynamic of internally
between the three commands I like that
they already know each other
and they kind of have a little bit of an
established thing but also you know
something that has a room for growth
because you know you you've got writing
as who knew each other from way back but
obviously haven't been caught up in a
while and obviously Graham in his
relationship with Ryan is a little bit
weird for a number of reasons so you
know there's they have an established
dynamic but there's also room for growth
and I think that's that has a lot of
promise in it the thing that we were
dealing with you know with the with the
hunter with the teeth that's kind of an
unsettling thing like the teeth it
honestly was and I mean that any good
way and his little electro tentacle
thing which also was what an on its
initial reveal was impressively
unsettling because it was so dark II
just sort of see these tentacles coming
through this door and this lightning
arcing is like what the hell is that I
get first it was like that's like
Cthulhu stuff what is going on there so
design on these things was pretty good
was pretty interesting the backstory
motivation on them was functional you
know got the job done and I mean I guess
that's kind of my feeling about this
episode overall it's not bad there are
things that I wish that it did that it
didn't do more things that I wish were a
little bit different from what it did
but it gets the job done it establishes
the doctor it establishes you know these
these companions it ends on a odd kind
of cliffhanger for me like I
I don't like the moment it ends on like
I'll say that flatly that I didn't like
I'm like yeah that's that's that's the
kind of very forced sort of cliffhanger
that just bugs me say oh they're in a
deadly situation like yeah and they're
all gonna be fine within 20 seconds of
the serve the next episode like that
that always annoys me I mean I like that
the doctor screwed up I like that the
doctor is still capable of screwing up
that's something I like and appreciate
but I don't like that as an ending
moment the sonic screwdriver the new
sonic screwdriver it's cool looking I
like the orange glow I think that's got
that's a nice distinct look to it and
and I do I do like that and and I kind
of like the idea that she puts it well I
think the moment where I smiled the
biggest was where she picked up the
spoon just kind of stared at it for a
minute because I know it seems like
nobody else likes robots of Sherwood
other than me but I liked that episode
and I love I'm the doctor and this is my
spoon that that is one of my favorite
moments from earlier Capaldi episodes
like I love that so much and I felt like
just a little just taking him home like
oh the spoon and I like that quite a bit
so I like you know her being resourceful
and throwing stuff together and getting
things going she's a little bit
scatterbrained she seems to be
channeling a little bit of Smith's sort
of mmm this no this no this wait stop me
okay well I mean not just met Tennant
did that I mean the sort of the
fast-talking that a lot of the doctors
have had and a little bit scattershot
now we'll see if that holds because
sometimes you can't always count on the
first episode of the way the doctors for
that to hold because you know you've
always got post regeneration walking
this and plus like stepping out of the
narrative the actors gonna become more
climbing it to the part as they go along
so
you know we'll see if that becomes a
fixed part of the characterization of
the doctor presently or if she is going
to kind of settle a little bit more yeah
it's kind of like I I wish I could see I
could see that I can step sowed right
away because I feel like I didn't get I
didn't come away feeling like I know who
this doctor is yet which again you know
to be fair regenitive first post
regeneration episode often the doctor
doesn't know completely who they are yet
but I do feel like usually I have more
of a grip on it than this
you know Tennant would have had his you
know no second chances I'm that kind of
man moment and Matt Smith
you know just settling on the bowtie or
you know Capaldi with his attack
eyebrows and I feel like Whitaker didn't
have that kind of moment you know
something that that is that is like the
first firm pull of what makes this
doctor different and I feel like I
didn't get that yet so I'm gonna be
watching for that
I think I'll wrap it up there I mean
overall it's good it's good it's solid
I'm not blown away by really any of it
yet but there was there really was
nothing that I thought was particularly
bad so I consider it solid it's
definitely something that can be built
on in terms of the characters the doctor
the companions all of it really and I'm
really want to see where it goes but I'm
not I'm not sold on this doctor yet
which again is not a damning thing it
can take a little bit of time with some
of these doctors sometimes they don't
always work immediately I mean go back I
mean I like Sylvester McCoy I'll go back
and watch some of his earliest episodes
it's rough going so you know in the age
of instantaneous feedback in
instantaneous opinions we're very quick
to leak to a file
clusion up therefore this sucks like no
you give it some time to breathe but I'm
still enjoying her I'm just I haven't
completely hooked in yet I'm hoping to
though so we'll see so that's gonna wrap
it up for me folks the woman who fell to
earth what did you think about it and
even if your opinion on it was negative
please keep the comments at least
politely worded I know that there's
still a lot of strong opinions about the
the direction of Doctor Who as a show so
you know express whatever you want but
like no personal attacks not on me not
on the people involved just don't do
that okay
cuz I'll delete it so whatever your
thoughts are within those parameters
drop something down in the comments
let's talk about it there's a whole
bunch of stuff to do so because there's
buttons and there's links and all those
sorts of things there's a link to the
patreon if you feel like supporting me
that way so that's gonna wrap it up for
this one folks
I'll be back to do the next one next
Monday I don't know I'll probably still
do like maybe my doctor classic review
and my Big Finish review for the month
yeah you know still on Sundays but I'm
not gonna have always Doctor Who content
on Sunday for as long as I'm doing these
on the Mondays that follow so that will
wrap it up for now and until next time
folks remember you're the council and I
just run the meetings and until next
time this council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]